العمل الوحشي هنا لم
يشهده العالم ولكن بمجرد ظهور نتائجه
من الغرب يكون لديهم كلمات
وأسلحة دعم ولكن هنا هم
وحدهم
في الحرارة الحارقة المغطاة بالغبار في
الهجوم المضاد الجنوبي بالقرب من أورهاييف تمتلك
أوكرانيا زمام المبادرة
ومع ذلك فإنهم  يجب أن يطلقوا النار في طريقهم
للأمام جولة تلو الأخرى،
شكرًا لك، لقد
تجاوز الروس المبنى الذي يلوح
في الأفق،
فلنواصل التحرك يا رفاق،
إنهم قلقون جدًا من مغادرتنا،
نحن أول الصحفيين الذين يصلون إلى
هذا الجزء من الهجوم المضاد الأوكراني الذي
يدفع جنوبًا نحو  روبرتينا،
لذا فهم متأكدون تمامًا من أن
الروس قد رصدوا الدبابة، ولذا فإننا الآن
نتحرك بسرعة للخروج من هنا لأنهم
يتوقعون ردًا على النيران، فالخسائر الناجمة عن
هجماتهم المبكرة تظهر بوضوح هذه
المركبة المدرعة برادلي التي زودتها الولايات المتحدة بها وسط هذا الغبار الكثيف.  هذه الناقلات التي
نتحرك للأمام لإطلاق النار على
المواقع الروسية التي يقولون إنها بدأت
تبدو في خطر مع
تقدم الهجوم المضاد الجنوبي لأوكرانيا للأمام، فقد
الحرس الوطني الخامس عشر العديد من
الأصدقاء هنا ولكنه اكتسب أيضًا أرضًا،
كان الأمر صعبًا بشكل لا يصدق ولكن
رأينا بعض الوجوه  على مدار الأسبوع الماضي،
اقتربت روبيرتينا المشرقة من
بعض التقييمات لمعركتهم
والأدوات الممنوحة لعظمائها
هنا، حيث يُتوقع منهم القيام بأشياء
لن يحاول أي جيش من قوات الناتو القيام بها باستخدام
المعدات التي قد يسخرون منها في
عربة الهمفي التي نسافر بها.  مع إطارات رثة جدًا،
لا يُتوقع من أي جندي أمريكي
أن يقودها، ليس لديهم وقت
لتقييم أنهم
يفشلون في
الخارج
بسبب المشكلة الرئيسية، التفوق الجوي الروسي
وقنابل نصف طن التي يسقطونها
في أي لحظة، قد لا يهم مقدار
التغطية  لقد
احتمينا في قبو ذات يوم،
سقط 20 صاروخًا في عدة دقائق،
الوزن الآن هو ما يعتقدون أنه
صاروخ آخر يأتي ويهبط،
رائحة الموت تطارد الأنقاض
حيث تمزقت حياة بأكملها
الآن كان هذا
نقطة المساعدات الإنسانية الرئيسية في المدينة،
وقبل أسابيع، كان هذا هو المكان الذي كان
يختبئ فيه السكان المحليون المتبقون
للاحتماء من الغارات الجوية، لكنه تعرض
لضربة مباشرة وفقد
عدد لا بأس به من الأشخاص حياتهم عندما
وقع هذا الانفجار، لا يزال بإمكانك شم رائحة
الانفجار.  في الهواء
في عالم الاستهداف المشوه في موسكو،
هؤلاء الرجال هم المسعفون العسكريون الذين
يشعرون بأنهم مطاردون،
العالم السري الذي يعيشون فيه
مخفي حيث تم
قصف آخر نقطتين لفرزهم،
وفي الساعات الثلاث يوميًا التي يقضونها
فوق الأرض، هذا هو  ما يحدث،
هذه لقطات نادرة لخطهم الأمامي
ينقذ
مسكنات الألم ومن الواضح أنها ليست كافية نعم نعم نعم
نعم
العلاجات المقدمة بسرعة تصل إلى 100 ميل في
الساعة
على الطرق الوعرة المقصوفة يبدو
معجزة أن يقوم أي شخص بذلك
في الجزء الخلفي من هذه المركبة المدرعة وليس
لدى الجميع
هذه التحويلات  مركباتهم
المتجمعة معًا ربما تكون مرئية
للطائرات الروسية في
بعض الأحيان لا يعودون جميعًا يوم
الجمعة أصيب زميلهم المسعف أندريه البالغ من العمر 33 عامًا
بالمدفعية،
ودفنوه يوم الاثنين
مقاطع فيديو أجنبية
أجنبية،
إنهم بحاجة إلى إنهاء الحرب في أشهر
ولكن ليس سنوات ولكن بدون مقابل  ولكن
بقي الغبار
نيك بايتون والش سي إن إن أو يتنفس أوكرانيا